e aí nós amiguinhos o vídeo da festa
assim a radicalização mesmo andando de
moto porque comigo é assim lá para lá
para a fada lapada também aqui com um
amigo
beleza
pois é já chegamos aqui no sítio mas
vamos do lado de fora aquele velho
cadeado que impede as pessoas os ladrões
até nós mesmos nem tão pouco
não sei por que comprar o iphone essas
folhas procura mas foi na amazônia dilma
cadê wifi no mapa o foco de sei lá cara
me tão contato mas a galera já vai
chegar e e hoje a gente vai se divertir
e montam que não fazem hoje vôlei partiu
hoje aquele velho vôlei como sempre
agora só ofende não acha que ele agora
agora só espera a ideia deve tá chegando
aí é isso aí que há pouco no fmi
to catatau kkkk gato catar já tá tá tá
tá tá tá galera agora a gente vai
conhecer uma nova espécie de animal a
gente acorde já pode ver que ele está se
aproximando
vamos lá vem comigo essa área é uma área
abandonada então tome cuidado
esse é um animal muito agressivo ele só
tem aqui no norte da ilha que a gente tá
tailândia aqui só tem no norte da
tailândia
vem com a gente conseguir avistá lo
esse aqui é o nome científico de cinema
e joão neto os morteiros e só sobrevive
aqui na tailândia
a gente não pode mexer nele que é um
animal de sangue é assim o único do
cairo com vara curta
quem só você encara o são paulo nesta
sexta-feira importado pessoas são mero
cantor para estou indo para minha
fazenda e votei a favor da ok a gente vê
por aí tá bom nessa cara e aí a assistir
o canal primeira vez que esse esse é
centrada sai no final eu falar esse dia
tava difícil gravar porque eu estava em
um esse sítio etapa difícil levar sua
câmera estava com medo dessa cama e tal
chuva em directo na rede do vôlei choveu
todos os dias chover eu fiquei com medo
de levar a câmera então por isso o vídeo
foi um foi ruim para o mercado tentará
nightwish ele realmente queria ser
feitos nos limites bom gente o então
pessoa maravilhosa tá são poucas pessoas
que têm um dom que ele tem e eu estou
pelo meio e entra e saí tribunal para o
verdão e ele dizer que eu curto muito o
trabalho dele que vocês têm me perdoe
volta lá logo bem o que você fala do
índio que é um princípio ele é um penso
gente tiver um presidente que é uma
pessoa muito boa o processo é uma pessoa
muito boa e super humilde seu presidente
a gente boa
e assim terminou venda bosta de hoje mas
eu prometo que o de amanhã vai ser bem
legal tá ok tá então será que li gostei
por caridade que hoje eu sei que não
merece mais e dá por caridade assim já
vamos incentivar o rapaz vou dar um
beijo vocês direito a quadrilha